that's like such like an iconic like
character so to see yourself in it's
kind of surreal it's a bird it's a plane
it's Tyler hoechlin dishing on playing
the new Superman on Supergirl
have you done the Cape yet I've had a
couple fittings it's a positive when
when the news came out everyone was like
yes yeah I was like literally I was like
straight up the first time I heard it I
was like perfect
I'm not trying to actively make it light
or unlike any of the other
representations of them really just
trying to do it specific to what I find
interesting about the character they'll
be fun it's definitely been a fun few
months for the 28 year old he played in
Sunday's MLB celebrity softball game
even earning MVP honors Tyler also had a
standout performance in the 80's
baseball comedy everybody wants some out
now on blu-ray and DVD we'll keep it
that way
films cast includes Glen Powell and J
Quinton Johnson I want to see you guys
that's that's just the 80s it was all
pelvis all the time plus Lake Jenner
who's married to Melissa Benoist aka
Supergirl did starring with supergirls
husband have anything to do with your
cat stickers that pure coincidence I
think it's a pure coincidence but it's
awesome Alyssa spent some time on set
and she's fantastic we all love her so
it'll be nice to get up there and be you
know shooting with a friendly face and a
friendly person